BACK TOMORROW, APM, SEAN HANNITY
RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: RA, TUCKER,
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," WE START
WITH A TOP NEWS ALERT.
A TONIGHT BOMBSHELL STORY
SURROUNDING THE DEEP STATE AND
THE UPCOMING FISA REPORT,
EXPECTED ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT.
THIS MIGHT EXPLAIN EVERYTHING
PAIRED REMEMBER, WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE GETTING THE FISA
REPORT IN MAY, JUNE, JULY,
AUGUST, ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
AG BARR SAID HE EXPECTED THE
REPORT IN MAY.
IF THE REPORT WE ARE LEARNING
ABOUT TONIGHT IS TRUE, WE MIGHT
NOW HAVE AN EXPLANATION FOR THE
ENTIRE HOLD UP.
LOOK AT THIS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR HAS EXPRESSED
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE KEY
FINDING IN THE UPCOMING
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
SURROUNDING THE ORIGINS OF THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
FIRST, THAT IS A GOOD THING,
BECAUSE REMEMBER THAT IS WHAT
THE DURUM INVESTIGATION IS ALL
ABOUT.
AT LEAST THE BEGINNINGS OF THAT,
BUT THAT IS ALSO BECOME
OFFICIALLY A CRIMINAL PROBE THAT
HAS EXPANDED INTO ALL THINGS
FISA AND OTHER THINGS, AND
ACCORDANT TO MY SOURCES TONIGHT
WHILE THE IG WILL CONFIRM A TON
OF DAMNING INFORMATION,
DEVASTATING INFORMATION ON THE
DOJ, THE FBI, THE FISA
APPLICATIONS, APPARENTLY THERE
HAS BEEN SOME DISAGREEMENT, A
LITTLE UNWILLINGNESS OF THE
OBAMA APPOINTED INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO TAKE THE KNEADING
STEPS TO SAY ONE AND ONE EQUALS
TWO.
IN OTHER WORDS, TO BLUNTLY SAY
WHAT IT IS.
AND BY THE WAY, BEHIND THE
SCENES I AM TOLD THERE HAS BEEN
A BRUTAL BACK AND FORTH, YOU CAN
ADD SIMPLE MATH, RIGHT?
APPARENTLY THAT LINE HAS BEEN
USED NUMEROUS TIMES.
ATTORNEY GENERAL REPORTEDLY
BELIEVES THAT THERE WAS NOT
SUFFICIENT BASIS.
AND THIS IS WHERE THE DURUM
REPORT COMES INTO OPEN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN 2016.
HORWITZ ALLEGEDLY EXPECTED TO
DELIVER A MUCH DIFFERENT FINDING
ON THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THAT WAS NOT HIS
EARLY MANDATE.
HIS MANDATE WAS TO LOOK INTO
FISA ABUSE.
THIS WOULD EXPLAIN THE DELAY,
AFTER DELAY, AFTER DELAY, AND
ALSO THE RECENT LEAKING THAT HAS
BEEN GOING ON WHICH HAS BEEN
RAMPANT.
ASSUMING THIS IS TRUE OF THE
OBAMA APPOINTED HORWITZ DOES NOT
CONCLUDE ON THE BASIC ISSUES
THAT WE ALL KNOW TO BE
ESTABLISHED FACT, PREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON THE FISA COURT,
REPEATEDLY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE AG IS
SIGNALING THAT THE DURHAM REPORT
IS WHERE ALL OF THE ACTION WILL
BE ON EVERYTHING.
AND WE DO NEED TO REMEMBER A
COUPLE OF IMPORTANT FACTS HERE.
REMEMBER THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
HAS NO POWER TO CONVENE A GRAND
JURY.
HAS NO POWER TO BRING
INDICTMENTS PIT HAS NO POWER TO
BRING IN CHARGES.
DURUM DOES HAVE ALL OF THAT
POWER.
AND REMEMBER THAT THIS IS NOW
OFFICIALLY A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION THAT HAS EXPANDED
INTO MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT
WILL BEGIN NEXT WEEK'S REPORT.
AND AGAIN, I HEAR IT IS VERY,
JUST READING THE FACTS.
ALSO, ANOTHER IMPORTANT THING TO
REMEMBER, HORWITZ ALREADY
CONCLUDED BOTH McCABE AND
COMEY LIED.
THAT THEY LACKED CANDOR.
BY THE WAY, THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS A BIG DEAL WHEN IT WAS
A TRUMP ASSOCIATE.
AND BY THE WAY, AND THOSE TWO
CASES, NOTHING HAPPENED.
REMEMBER?
HE MADE REFERRALS, NOTHING
HAPPENED.
THE IG DOES NOT MAKE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS.
HE MAKES REFERRALS TO
INVESTIGATE.
FUNNY, BECAUSE CANDOR GOT
MICHAEL COHEN, PAUL MANAFORT,
MOST RECENTLY ROGER STONE IN
TIMES OF TROUBLE.
THE SYSTEM IS SO CORRUPT,
FRANKLY, REPULSIVE.
WE HAVE A DUAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND DON'T FORGET, THIS IS WHAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SIGNALED IN
A RECENT SPEECH.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT NO ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES
WOULD SAY THIS UNLESS YOU KNOW
SOMETHING WE DON'T KNOW.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IMMEDIATELY AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON ELECTION,
OPPONENTS INAUGURATED WHAT THEY
CALLED "THE RESISTANCE."
AND THEY RALLIED AROUND AN
EXPLICIT STRATEGY OF USING EVERY
TOOL, AND MANEUVER TO SABOTAGE
THE FUNCTIONING OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION.
NOW, RESISTANCE IS THE LANGUAGE
USED TO DESCRIBE INSURGENCY
AGAINST RULE IMPOSED BY AN
OCCUPYING MILITARY POWER.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS AND
INDEED INCENDIARY NOTION TO
IMPORT INTO THE POLITICS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC.
>> Sean: I WOULD BUCKLE UP AS
A COUNTRY, THAT SOUNDS AS
SERIOUS AS IT CAN GET.
MUCH MORE ON THAT STRAIGHT
AHEAD.
LINDSEY GRAHAM, REMEMBER, IT
WEEK FROM THIS WEDNESDAY, HE
WILL HAVE HORWITZ BEFORE HIS
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE AND
RESPOND EXCLUSIVELY TO THIS
DEVELOPING STORY TONIGHT.
ALSO BUCKLE UP, THE MONTH
OF DECEMBER IS ABOUT TO BE ONE
OF THE MOST PIVOTAL TIMES IN
MODERN AMERICA HISTORY.
LOOK AT THIS, AS WE SPEAK, HOUSE
DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE BEEN ON
THIS QUEST FOR THREE YEARS
RACING AGAINST THE CLOCK,
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO WRAP UP
THEIR HALF ASKED YOU CRANING
IMPEACHMENT CHARADES SINCE
CHRISTMAS.
AND MANY DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS
ARE ANXIOUSLY WAITING THE
FINDINGS OF A REAL INVESTMENT
INTO CORRUPTION AND TO THE VERY
OF REAL ABUSE OF POWER.
THE FISA REPORT WILL BE PUBLIC
ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT, AND NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN, SOFTBALL
INTERVIEW APPEARS AT THE DAILY
BASED.
THEY LOVE ME AT THAT PAPER.
THE FBI ATTORNEY LISI PAGE
PAINTING YOURSELF AS AN INNOCENT
VICTIM JUST TRYING TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT'S
UNFOUNDED ATTACKS.
LET ME EDUCATE THE SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS IN THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA.
LISA PAGE IS NEITHER INNOCENT
NOR A VICTIM.
SHE CARRIED OUT WHAT WAS A
LENGTHY AFFAIR WITH A TOP
INVESTIGATOR AT THE FBI NAMED
PETER STRZOK.
THEIR PERSONAL BUSINESS IS THEIR
BUSINESS.
BUT THE TWO OF THEM INSERTED THE
RAMPANT POLITICAL BIAS, YES,
INTO HIGHLY SENSITIVE TOP-NOTCH
INVESTIGATIONS INCLUDING THE
PROBE INTO HILLARY CLINTON'S
SECRET SERVER.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU WANT REAL
OBSTRUCTION, THAT WOULD BE THE
BLEACH BIT THAT DELETED
SUBPOENAED EMAILS, ET CETERA.
IN THE COLLUSION ON THE CAMPAIGN
AGAINST TRUMP, THE DOSSIER.
REMEMBER THEY WERE USING THEIR
WORK PHONES AND WHY
ROBERT MUELLER DID NOT DEMAND
THAT THEY BE HANDED OVER AND WE
DO A SEARCH OF ALL OF IT IS
ANYBODY'S UNDERSTANDING.
ANYWAY, HER AND STRZOK WERE
OBSESSING ABOUT THEIR HATRED FOR
ALL THINGS DONALD TRUMP.
REMEMBER, THE SPRING OF 2016,
PAGE TEXTING THAT TRUMP WAS A
"LOW SONY HUMAN BEING" REFERRING
TO HIM AS A GIANT [BLEEP].
PETER STRZOK AGREED TWEETING
"TRUMP IS AN IDIOT.
HILLARY CLINTON SHOULD WIN 1/0."
OVER THE TEXTS UNHINGE, THE
AGENT BONDING OVER COMPULSIVE
HATRED FOR DONALD TRUMP, THE
PLOT TO STOP HIM FROM EVER
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUST
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUS,
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSO
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSL
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSY
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSE
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSG
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUST
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSD
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSY
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND ON AUGUSS
AFTER JIM COMEY OPEN HIS
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AFTER I WOULD ARGUE
THEY GAVE HILLARY CONSIDERATIONS
THAT NO AMERICAN WOULD EVER GET,
LISA PAGE SAID THIS DESPERATE TO
TEXT TO HER BEST FRIEND, HER BFF
LOVER.
"TRUMP IS NOT EVER GOING TO
BECOME PRESIDENT, RIGHT?"
STRZOK TEST BACK, NO, NO, WE
WILL STOP IT.
A FEW DAYS LATER TELLING PAGE
THAT I WANT TO SHOW THE PATH
THAT YOU THROUGHOUT AND
CONSIDERATION IN ANDY'S OFFICE
THAT THERE IS NO WAY THAT HE
GETS ELECTED.
I'M AFRAID WE CANNOT TAKE THAT
RISK.
IT IS LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY
IN THE LIKELY EVENT THAT YOU DIE
BEFORE YOUR 40.
WE WILL STOP IT.
INSURANCE POLICY.
THOSE ARE NOT TEXT BETWEEN TWO
LOW LEVEL EMPLOYEES IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THOSE WERE TWO OF THE MOST
POWERFUL INDIVIDUALS WORKING AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBI
AND INVOLVED IN THE RIGGED
INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY CLINTON.
IN MASSIVE CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
ITSELF.
IN FACT, STRZOK WAS THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR IN THE CLINTON
EMAIL PROBE, REMEMBER THAT HE IS
INTERROGATING HILLARY CLINTON,
BUT SHE GETS TO BRING TWO OTHER
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE CASE FOR
SUPPORT.
NOBODY ELSE GETS THAT
CONSIDERATION.
AND BY THE WAY, REMEMBER, THEY
CHANGE THE WORDS YEAH, TO NOT BE
THE LEGAL STANDARD.
ANYWAY, ALSO LEADING THE COUNTER
ENTAIL AN CROSS FIRE HURRICANE
INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ONLY
DAYS AFTER THEY EXONERATED
THEIR FAVORITE CAN I GET ONLY
MEANT CANDIDATE THAT SHOULD WIN
100-0.
LISA PAGE WAS A CLOSE ADVISER TO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
ANDREW MCCABE, AUGUST 2016 THE
PAIR WAS DISCUSSING WAYS TO USE
AN ALL-POWERFUL POSITION TO STOP
DONALD TRUMP, UP AND HIS
PRESIDENCY WITH THEIR INSURANCE
POLICY AT THE READY IN THE
UNLIKELY EVENT THAT TRUMP BEAT
THEIR FAVORITE CANDIDATE
HILLARY CLINTON.
AND IT WAS ALL DONE IN AN
OFFICIAL CAPACITY USING THEIR
WORK PHONES.
LISA PAGE IS NOT A VICTIM.
SHE RESIGNED IN DISGRACE.
HER LOVER, PETER STRZOK, FIRED
BY THE FBI ALONG WITH ALL OF
THESE OTHER GUYS, FIRED,
RESIGNING, DEMOTED.
AND ROBERT MUELLER'S FORMER PIT
BULL ANDREW WEISSMANN, A LONG
HISTORY OF LOCKING UP INNOCENT
PEOPLE, HIDING EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE.
YOU WANT TO PROVE, READ CINDY
POWELL'S BOOK.
LICENSED ALIVE LIVE.
STICKING UP FOR HIS TRUMP HATER
SAYING SHE DID NOTHING WRONG.
SHOCKING, THE DEEP STATE, THEY
SUPPORT EACH OTHER.
>> LISA PAGE HAS DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
SHE HAS A FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT
TO SPEAK, ALSO AS A FEDERAL
EMPLOYEE.
AND IT IS JUST A FICTION TO
THINK THAT JURORS, JUDGES,
BATTLE EMPLOYEES DO NOT HAVE
POLITICAL VIEWS.
THE ISSUE IS WHETHER THEY ACT ON
THEM.
PEOPLE ACT ON PRINCIPLE ALL THE
TIME.
JURORS DO IT, JUDGES DO IT,
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS DO IT.
AND IT IS SIMPLY NOT THE CASE TO
THINK THAT PERSONAL VIEWS ARE
GOING TO AFFECT WHAT A
PROSECUTOR DOES.
>> Sean: PRETTY AMAZING, MS
DNC, THE CONSPIRACY THEORY
CHANNEL.
AMAZING HOW ANDREW WEISSMANN HAS
TURNED INTO THE GREAT DEFENDER
OF CEREBRAL LIBERTIES AFTER
LEADING A BASELESS WITCH HUNT IN
LEADING A BASELESS WITCH HUNT IO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AS YOU CAN SEE, CLEARLY THE
DEEP STATE IS IN PANIC MODE
AHEAD OF NOT ONLY THE FISA
REPORT, BUT THE DURHAM CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, AND IT NOW ALL
BEGINS TO MAKE SENSE.
THE TIMING OF PAGE'S INTERVIEW
IS NOT A COINCIDENCE.
NEITHER IS THE PERSON WHO
INTERVIEWED HER.
FOXNews.com, THEY POINT OUT
PAGE USED AND ABUSIVELY BIASED
TRUMP HATING WRITER TO BREAKER
SILENCE AHEAD OF THE IG REPORT.
NO SOFTBALL INTERVIEW IS EVER
GOING TO COVER UP DISTORTED
ACTIONS, THE REVEALING POLITICAL
BIAS IN HER TEXT WITH